bad thing though is that I don't know if
this is bad but I've been trying to
think about like business post post
Corona business mm-hmm
I think Amazon was like on the track to
potentially get him broken up by the
government you know like when you have
so much influence in one part of the
market right there antitrust laws that
are in place to potentially break you up
because you might have a monopoly right
and you might create a situation where
there isn't fair competition and
capitalism thrives off competition right
is this coming from like some knowledge
you have or just a theory
I think it's like a theory but it's also
like based on just like past research
and like little like conversations I've
heard people were saying that about
Walmart before I'm gone came along yeah
yeah yeah and I think Walmart was
probably close Walmart just has such a
stranglehold on like the American
workforce right they employ so many
[ __ ] people there'd be like a big
deal but AT&T got broken up like this
has happened before and I think Amazon
was going that in that direction right
anytime you influence the market too
much you can be broken up right here's
the problem the reason why Amazon hasn't
been touched is usually a company is
broken up when the consumer is punished
by that company being a monopoly in
other words let's say what was it
Standard Oil was at the Rockefeller oil
company Standard Oil something like that
I believe was Sandra Wroclaw
ran you know oil right he could charge
whatever the [ __ ] he wanted for oil if
he want he could do $30 a gallon there
was no other place to go get gas for
your [ __ ] car right so you get
punished
the thing about Amazon is even if it is
a monopoly
it's this weird monopoly in that it just
makes [ __ ] more affordable for the
consumer yeah
so everybody's hesitant to break it up
cuz they're like we're just kind of
benefiting from this right now the scary
thing is what happens when they're the
only game in town then they don't have
to make things better for the consumer
they could actually make things worse
and there's nobody to compete with that
to keep the prices down hmm so I
remember what won't say again no I just
don't think you'll be broken up only
because they allow other people to sell
stuff on em so this is what they've been
doing so Amazon is genius they allow
other people to sell [ __ ] on that on
Amazon right and they track the sales
right and then if it's a really good
selling item they make the same item and
then promote it to the people who have
bought that item for example we have a
bag that we travel with right yeah it
carries all of our camera gear the first
bag we got was not from Amazon then
Amazon started making the exact same bag
for cheaper and we bought that bag
that's right so they could create an
unfair practice with the consumption of
goods and they could also promote their
products over other ones so it wouldn't
be an even playing field yeah right so I
understand where this could go
that being said they don't get touched
after corona because they might be one
of the few businesses that's actually
doing well yeah so you can't break up a
business that's actually doing well you
need those businesses so it's gonna be a
really tough time for new businesses to
be created because Amazon will come out
of this way strong are way better than
they were in the first place with way
more market share and way more
confidence consumer confidence right
there's gonna be amazing time for Amazon
after Corona right here's the thing very
hard for startups to pop up after Amazon
or sorry after Corona because they'll be
they'll be coming up in the toughest
time in business there'll be nobody with
capital to invest right and very few
consumers to purchase the products that
they're selling right that being said
the companies that come out of the post
corona economy will be the most
successful companies for the next 50
years minimum hmm they're bein right I'm
not afraid of the dark I was born in it
I live in it I'm comfortable here you
know I'm saying they're companies that
will be incredibly lean and a [ __ ]
credibly efficient be
they were born out of poverty they were
born out of a situation where there was
bare bones to function so they found a
way to function with almost nothing and
become profitable with almost nothing so
when the economy starts to turn around
those companies are gonna [ __ ]
flourish so I think it's actually a
really cool time because whatever
companies look successful coming at us
that are new and again don't trust me
about investments [ __ ] just yet I
haven't figured it out but I would be
personally bullish on those companies
kind of like whoa you found a way to
succeed now you found a way to thrive
now when abundance comes back you were
gonna be Gucci and I didn't want to just
offer the advice
somebody mentioned this to me anybody
interested in starting a business like
if you're at home and you have more time
like really get all your you know ducks
in a row like get all your stuff ready
because the moment this is over they're
going to be throwing money on they're
gonna be throwing money during it yeah
and during it it's gonna be so easy to
get a business loan small business loan
a start-up loan so it's like if you have
all your [ __ ] in place and you really
were thinking about all right when am I
gonna start my business now's the time
it's just it is but it is no nope it's
to start it after once everybody's back
into like yeah and then being that yeah
that might be another 1224 months that's
the tricky thing dude yeah it's so it's
like I want you to be bullish but at the
same time I can't advise it just because
people are gonna start losing their jobs
they start losing their jobs they don't
have money to spend they can't spend how
are people gonna buy your product
something that gives it out like when
people are back to work exactly so now
it's timing it so now it's like figuring
out what the market needs figure out
what could survive a pandemic what kind
of business is always there like toilet
paper ain't going nowhere you got a
better version of toilet paper no no I'm
saying like nobody found a way to make
wet wipes go on the roll find a way to
make wet wipes go on the roll if you can
make wet wipes go on a roll and not go
dry you might have a business right
there's something there's something
there right so it's like figure out the
things that could exist dirt
pandemic figure out the things we really
need all these people are making these
[ __ ] businesses that are completely
unnecessary that we don't actually need
there were only functions of abundance
right like here I have a head massage
business just come and get your head
massage all this like what the [ __ ] it's
like how great is your week that you're
like I'm gonna go just get my head
massage that [ __ ] is gon be only the
necessities